so what are you making these comments
from Goldman Sachs young hot see is the
economist Lloyd Blankfein chief
executive don't raise rates well
everybody IIIi don't think anybody has
an idea let alone the Fed or whether he
should raise rates or not going into
this meeting and there's a lot of
ambiguity amongst participants as well
as in the marketplace what's also
important this is not only the rate hike
but also or if not or but also the
message isn't going to be a dovish
forecast or a hawkish so what are you
telling your clients about tomorrow
someone must be calling you and saying
Robert what do you think they're going
to do I need to position the the
portfolio well one thing we've been
looking at is and that is maybe cost for
the Fed to say well not this time but
maybe in december which is the risk for
another government shutdown at a debt
ceiling in 2013 Ben Bernanke decided not
to taper in September but postponed it
to December because of the risk of a
government shuts out what you think
that's going to help in tomorrow I think
that that is a risk and that is
something they by taking consideration
because the friction in Congress has
escalated over the last couple of weeks
meaning that they may have a continuing
resolution of all maybe two months which
will coincide with the next time that
the debt ceiling will be breached and US
government may go into technical default
and we know those kind of discussions
when the hammer Falls really is very
very iffy it seems look what do you what
are the markets think about this I mean
they missed the boat in 2011 they
haven't gone since then if they miss the
boat again now will they ever go well
you know you read a lot of research that
says basically you know a rate increase
is not necessarily the death bell for a
bull market in stocks obviously every
situation is different and we had a
pretty interesting story overnight by lu
wang and danny burger on our team that
looked at how this is different as far
as the corporate profit cycle no it's
obviously very late in the cycle to
start raising interest rates and they
looked at some interesting numbers from
Ned David research that said of all the
rate increases going back to World War 2
earnings growth has been averaging about
16
% in the year before the rate increase
that's not the case now now we're
looking at very very weak earnings
growth in fact last quarter we saw
earnings shrink for the first time in
this expansion so it's kind of a very
you know a perilous on earnings for the
sp500 are shrinking or have been lower
than they were in the past right right
okay and now you get this rate increase
history what does that tell us about the
future corporate profits and stock
prices so historically when the right
guy comes the initial rate hike like
this it's during a very booming time in
corporate profits growth of about
sixteen percent what Ned Davis research
found out is that then in the year
afterwards that growth is sliced in
about half to about eight percent or so
this time we're going into the situation
with much weaker earnings growth so it
could have an even worse worse effect
Robert is it possible that the Fed has
just missed this cycle I mean that we're
not going to see any increases now yeah
I totally agree with this dilemma but
the Fed is in a pickle because they said
they were going to raise rates sometime
in 2015 unless the world falls apart and
if they don't do it they'll lose
credibility their data dependent they're
so data dependent their data dependent
but you didn't listen to Janet Yellen
she would tell you that they are data
dependent they depend on the data are we
all data dependent yes but so they take
the can be data dependent and raise
rates no matter what come hell or high
water well they're looking at the
unemployment rates all right and so one
of the two targets for the Fed has been
met so they can hide behind that and say
okay now it's time to raise rates and
also they were normalized policy going
into the presidential election next year
can I just try to summarize you're
saying that possibly most likely they're
going to raise rates in December not
tomorrow yes yes okay and you're saying
that corporate profits are not doing
well and this increased 25 basis points
go ahead yeah the corporate profit
footing is not on a great footing right
outset to absorb this that said I don't
know how closely Janet Yellen monitors
corporate profit growth if only maybe as
an indication where unemployment is
gonna go so I just want to the question
I want to pose to both is based on the
performance not of the domestic economy
but the based on all of the upsets
outside the United States does that
influence the
decision by the Federal Reserve well
that's the influences the decision by
the Federal Reserve indirectly so if it
starts to affect the US economy then it
will definitely weigh heavily into their
decision as long as it stays offshore so
to speak then the Fed is reluctant to
use that as the smoking gun to you to
decide to raise rates or not okay they
take note but they don't really care all
that much or some version of the hey art
thanks guys very good